Thanks I hate it I really do oh listen
I'm going away for five days and I need
to work in advance
reddit videos are really fun let me just
let me do it
thanks I hate the Chinese government
freak the Chinese government Thanks I
hate the Chinese government me too
what a coincidence Chinese government
diss track incoming question mark if
this video gets 1 billion thumbs up I
will drop the fattest diss track on the
Chinese government I don't even remember
tweeting this I think we're right
drinking Oh No
pew new Sabres I'm sorry Gloria Borger
isn't here anymore
Oh God China's like that one person on
Twitter that just can't take criticism
and just blocks every oh it's too
accurate one day this will all be yours
it was much nicer before nuclear fallout
but they still are Kingdom yes papa
Thanks I hate wait some men can be
pregnant in nuclear fallout I see this
as an absolute win thanks I like it oh
god what is that oh god thanks I hate
Halloween turnips
you know Halloween jack-o'-lanterns were
originally made out of turnips me I
wonder what that look odd yes I want to
do that whoa
so they made a lot of those oh my god Oh
God
Thanks I hate it war water taste and
cold water tastes pointing oh my god
that is so true I never thought of that
why would you say something so
controversial yet so brave Thanks I just
thanks does it bother people that I'm
not standing up anymore I wonder if
that's a thing it's just it did fit I'm
30 now guys I can't I don't have legs
what can I say I missed when Peter pie
would stand up in videos how about this
I'll sit on my leg I mean my penis
Thanks I hate minions even more now the
minions wear goggles because their eyes
outside of their skulls does that mean I
can suck on a minion eyeball thanks I
see this as absolute win Thanks I hate
sonic hedgehog penis is like a belly
button also that's what it is
I have a hedgehog and I always wonder
what that belly button thing Oh Oh God
oh girl
Instagram be like thanks Bart Baker's
Chinese videos be like that guy who's
awesome but check out this face filter
auto-tune what a [ __ ]
so what's the deal with the flame on
your tail it gave us my health
the bigger the flame the healthier I am
oh I have something like that watch
gourdel use water gun see that old blood
that isn't good doorbell noodle yeah
yeah so tell me how did this fear of
doorbells start well it started with my
pinky finger Oh God
okay but why do their finger have to go
in like that I don't know I and I again
I kind of want to suck it I'm not gonna
lie I'm not gay yes iam coachmen
explains throughout all yesterday we
really can't ever know how much fat and
other soft tissues contributed to
overall shape of dinosaurs since that's
the first thing to rot and shrivel so
fat dinosaurs could be a reality that's
awesome has ever been a fat animal in
the wild like a really grotesque animal
what animals are fat Oh brah Brooke
there it is there it is
lamang key lamang key everyone smash
like for la monkey 10,000 likes and i'll
make of a monkey montage thanks I hate
accidental hellbound and messes up
enlighten class the demon I just hope is
that the demon version of them a regular
dog there it is before and after
thanks I hate the early 2000 oh my god I
remember these yeah me too
we're a lawless wasteland easy squirt
funky purple oh yeah man I did not have
the purple one we shouldn't I have easy
squirt I just have easy squirt because
of all the gamer girls yeah the 2000s
were a lawless land oh my god that's
disgusting what would you put so much
the green one I had the green one god
what was wrong with us what was wrong
with our society what was wrong with our
society on the green one no god I still
have nightmares when I was a kid I
remember they had dyed food for
Halloween they made the potato mash
green everyone ate it except me joke
send them because they all died I take
no chances no one explained what food
coloring was and I didn't sing food a
different color and no one explained
what food coloring is okay I'm not gonna
trust some random kindergarten thought
I'm not I'm not gonna trust that it's
green we just dyed it what is dyed
explain yourself
her stinky hair was on fire was as well
it was epic it was the best day of my
life I remember seeing her back back up
to the candle there was a live candle in
the kindergarten and the teacher was she
was backing up slowly to this candle
while she was demonstrating something I
remember seeing it happen unveiling and
it was - it was the most beautiful why
do I always go off on tangents I'm sorry
protip instead of fake Halloween
decorations use front-facing MRI images
instead oh my god I hate it oh it's my
sleep paralysis David
oh god I've seen it before stop it if
donkeys nostrils had eyeballs yeah here
you have alpaca here you have alpha
connotes this is what Tickle Me Elmo
looks like without fur oh my god oh this
reminds me so Mars they asked me if she
can make a long Furby I should be on the
subreddit by the way long Furby it's
like thanks I hate it look look at that
look at that why would anyone want to
make that what is wrong with my wife
what have I done
it's awful thanks I hate look for every
there it is and I said no because I
don't want nightmares I have enough
nightmares as it is but apparently Willy
announcement of microwaves offer it to
create this monstrosity detach Furby
face attach base extend body install
snake robot Oh God
I'm thinking it moves around like a
snake while screaming at people I'd be
lying if I didn't admit part of me wants
to see this Thanks I hate red dead now
let's go Cowboys let's go Frank Ocean
and hotdog water are the same name if
you really think about it I don't know
why people hate hotdog water so much oh
god no oh God unfiltered hot dog water
Wow only $38 Wow
Millennials sure know how to spend their
money that's a great price also was in
sale hotdogs lip balm body fragrance are
you telling me what that's awesome how
can i buy that breath spray yeah that's
how you get mad puss that's how you get
a gamer girlfriend right there he's
brief smack hotdog vom bats are the only
animals in the world that produce
cube-shaped poo how how I like it I'm
fascinated
like square poo that's awesome oh my god
someone made plushies chocolate vomit
poo humanity was a mistake of Ombuds
minecraft character question mark but
why why they drop square poo it's
buttholes shaped like poo I don't
understand you learned so much on the PD
PI channel you have to admit it learnt a
neat way to change areas to a specific
color using the lab color gam okay you
can literally just use selective color
or whatever
anyway I present you flesh man group you
know yeah thanks I hate it wow that was
so difficult
I learned using carbs and like that's
right now blah blah blah Thanks I hate
reverse
centaurs yeah some of these are
fascinating to me okay
Oh God thanks I hate this chair I would
sit in it in the reverse order oh thanks
I hate FIGS hell what the truth about
the figures in case you didn't know figs
exists thanks to a special insect known
as the fig wash this was crawling to pit
figs and help them pulling it but on the
downside they live give birth and die in
the figs but don't worry as a fig ripens
it digests any and all bugs still dog
God inside of it so when you bite into
one you're getting old fruit and zero
ones no you wrote hey it's like that one
scene from Star Wars that was there for
some reason why was that scene there
remember that remember I need to suck on
that
thanks to hate Star Wars now why was
that there why why was that in I I don't
understand I still don't understand you
know someone's written a fanfiction
about Luke and that milk monster you
know it and you know I'm the one who
wrote it
stone Stu oh god that is so awesome I
love it I actually love it I'm not gonna
like this one is epic the first guy took
god I hate this meme the first guy to
break the fourth wall must have been
like yeah there it is thanks I hate this
mean format now yeah that's what ruining
it's what ruin name and it will never
come back
Thanks I hate balloon animals with
internal organs oh my god oh god oh god
oh this is torture I don't know if I'm
rooting for them or all god thanks I
hate this transition oh god I can't
explain this but Hotel air conditioners
feel how McDonald's sprite tastes what I
can't explain it but my mouth tastes
like saliva boy okay
girl I kind of want to try that hold up
yeah boy is easy you just do that right
I'm good at drawing yeah thanks
alistair girl i mean not bad right show
me yours on the subreddit okay this one
wins i'm sorry
yeah oh god why I just don't understand
yeah gosh dang Oh God
animations should be illegal I'm sorry
when an earthquake happens coffins
become underground maracas thanks for
that image thank you okay cue the enemy
girl
all right epic oh it's Hudson to me ah
thanks
I hate it oh god not animations please
oh god why would anyone want to torture
pika
that's the worst thing I've seen in my
life now I can I refuse I'm sorry I
refuse yeah why would you do that oh god
I want to apologize for Sweden because
apparent I didn't know this but
apparently sweetie tweet Sweden we put
bananas on pizzas and yeah I eat the
banana with a peel on I'm just kidding I
hate the pizza from the center but come
on this has to be worse wise millennial
humor so weird
Swedish Springs be like burning Jung
Byung it's true actually in physics
class when we study springs instead of
using the physics constant formula F
equals minus KX we have F equals burn
burn burn
[Laughter]
[Music]
oh god why Oh God the worst thing I've
ever seen no existence shouldn't be a
thing there's too many bad things it's
not worth it Thanks I hated lying woody
harrelson yeah I hate it I hate it
remember have a child Eliab woody
harrelson Thanks I hate reverse winter
Oh God now I'm gonna set now when she's
on her period and no I'm not reading
that it might no I'm not reading that
can I take it off dad just a bit longer
it's not quite ready okay that's enough
are you ready to talk now oh god the
bananas stop I hate swimming bananas
where does almond milk come from nobody
my brain loci kind of sexy now now suck
up some almond titties when you sit on a
toilet you're connecting your butthole
to a citywide network of connected
Buttle who comes up with these things
not only this award avacado come from
the ancient as the word testicle but the
word guacamole quite literally
translates to testicle sauce oh my god I
knew it I knew it this is the green
potato all over again I don't like
walking moley
I don't like avocado yes I said it oh
it's a super fruit I don't care it's
weird
I don't like it and I always knew there
was something wrong with it now I have
it now I have a valid reason to say no
enjoy your testicle size take a shower
oh you mean get pissed on by my own
house no thanks it's kind of cute I
don't hate it a note to all aspiring
novelist sometimes you should just use
said Snape ejaculated like wow wow good
writing
when Spotify tries to make me a daily
mix chocolate ramen noodles low-key want
to try it though come on that's not the
worst thing I've seen Arby's has flipped
the vegan meat trend on its head with
imaginable a carrot made of turkey that
looks and tastes almost exactly like the
vegetable why would you do that - why
stop I say stop me do you think
Chewbacca has pegs or a trail of tiny
teats
like a pig bleh oh my god driver why do
you sit in the front
I didn't realize now on uber you can see
your own rating my rating is 4 point 73
I didn't realize I was being raped -
this whole time I have very little
patience for people okay it's not my
fault so now I flipped the whole thing
on its head
you know how ober drivers always go
five-star they do it they always like PI
star by star as soon as you're about to
leave the car you're like all right
Thank You pie sir
all right thank you for the ride sir
have a good that place are now since
they are rating me I pull the fast one
on them I'm like he's like here's your
destination some I'm sorry if I start
okay thanks brough aye sir it's like
that meme right where oh god I cannot
stop driving overs remember that reddit
post oh I'm so addicted to Ober
well that's literally me now I'm I'm
taking ubers left and right just to get
my uber rating up come on
four point 273 that's terrible if you
have like a three star rating on uber
please share then please explain why I
want to know god that's awful that
material on your skin you know how hard
it's gonna be to remove those boots we
just walk around pretending it's not
weird that one of our hands is better at
stuff than the others oh my god yeah
that is weird I never thought of that
god dammit why well thanks I hate anime
now I think anime has been ruined enough
times already
our God is shower thoughts honey is the
tastiest of all the insect bonnets we
have tried so far yeah
I found this out recently it's vomit
honey is vomit and I found this out
because of the Minecraft update thanks
minecraft are they doing one of those
things where they can spread it yeah
it's kind of Awesome I don't hate it
this this channel is awesome by the way
it's a I think it's a Japanese guy that
makes knives out of different things
yeah this isn't even the best part the
knife is made of milk the channel name
is kiwami Japan you should check it out
it's really good thanks I hate it
ooh kiss-kiss kiss-kiss sick you sick
sis sis ah what kiss kisses huh zoom to
a new verse whose race is over
did you just conjugate in French me
that's great
Oh God I wrote code to unwrap my face
William Auslan why do you have to make
me hate everything I take it back don't
do the Furby the world is not ready for
it thanks I hate myself egg one of the
most popular forms of a child to eat
yeah yeah another thing you will never
have me eating you will never have me
eating green mashed potato you will
never have me a mean guac and you will
never have me eating egg egg jeez gross
it stinks it smells like crap I don't
care that it's a great source of protein
I don't care about anything regarding to
it it's disgusting and I'm gonna go
ahead and say too
milk is gross - you're sucking on titty
juice this is you this is new drinking
milk no I'm not a vegan I just think
it's repulsive
thanks I hate spiders even more now a
zombie spider spider covered in fungus
hat oh god I can't take spiders sorry
sorry I'm moving on I don't care what
it's about
oh these are great I think that's enough
of a hating things for one day I had a
lot of fun checking this subreddit out
if you enjoyed smash like if you like my
best you can buy my vest buy my best buy
my best
Sookie that market thank you guys and
I'll see you Morrow bye bye well you
haven't tried to pursue me later today
after 50 million out routes fetch down
just down it's still relevant
just down a bit